[Music]
posey modern week ahead of the black marl
me and with history today is billy
and now benchmark for the beam art gallery
who to experience about other for the
killing works for those lenders
international lenders and bringing the
barry finest materials here the columbia
university to share becomes at campus
arnhemmers aan de brother arco in public
ederson arno and the bubble edge to
complete neck
dissertation adler universally in 2014
and have an exhibition based on a
dissertation open and occasionally his food
on the shore it is gallery de now me
spend toilet art gallery
so a live action research coming out
or came in for cd and that never like
dissertation
was therefore spectacular investigation of
gender
kris and yves english and looking at a
bowl of the box kinomoto
this is a medium or color li
also the research into that
done by
a black bombs about
black women to web history and thirdly
the importance of this course will be an
simply but an art eye co li
the not who left on the bolt that
Sint Walibi oh the black female
finger in modern art eye level
no one
xplay just as nationally and timely and
compelling
heath the ride ride my cue extra bit
the number too but the black marl pro voice
an olympic
sql tuning where asia my nose olympia
achab's i went to just this on work
but have worked or arno slips it 60
generations and somewhat more and more
deeply into the archival and
and I the room and other information
about the subject
he walked back and forth just how extensive
and includes a legacy in a header
image of sarah managers
nothing is too crazy was the last hundred
sixty you so following posing modern idea
we go and which sleigh had the program
that companies the exhibition
dwb or course educational and reach
ok dual student can be scratched
colombia and toe brother grips
characterizes the show there will be an
academic symposia there may be a
ardie soon and other types of actividades
you allow the for president
exhibition hit
he with light shows the visitors from
the exhibition
how the curiosity you know my business
group in got images were highly images
and whether they mean a neuron times
and some demi informé ssrs and also the
global world optidee the fuck that
colombia is presenting knife and after this is
in harlow and one hundred and tony
competition is history and so minimoys
what time the hello is coming out
[Music]